well this week California Governor Gavin
Newsom is expected to ask lawmakers in
that state for 1.4 billion dollars to
fight homelessness of course if the
governor gets his money well do nothing
to reduce the incidence of homelessness
nothing they've tried in that state has
fundamentally the state's authorities
are unwilling to fix the core problem in
San Francisco police in action against
crime and vagrancy has become so bad
that heavily taxed locals are turning to
private police they're hiring their own
they have no choice that's the focus of
tonight's episode in our week-long
series American dystopia you know how
can I help you meet Cody Clemens San
Francisco Patrol special Clemens isn't
an ordinary cop in fact he's not a cop
at all so we're patrol special police
officers yes we are paid for by private
businesses merchants we spend two hours
riding along with Clement says he
fielded call after call over today
mostly about the destructive drug
addicts who lined the neighborhood
sidewalks outside the library which they
use as a day shelter why are they
reporting who's accosted by this man
if I wanted to write do you think you'll
be homeless for us to your life
that's your choice yeah the Castro
district is rich homes their cost as
much as four million dollars apiece the
residents are live on these streets they
pay for our service the area's richest
residents voted to create a community
benefit district that's bureaucratic
jargon for a private government to do
jobs that San Francisco's city
government won't do some of the most
common calls that I get from residents
somebody setting up a tent in front of
my house a homeless person going through
our garbage with they're making a mess
the benefit district pays people to
patrol the streets they trash and remove
graffiti now in most cities the city
government cities they would but not San
Francisco where property owners are
forced to pay mandatory fees to finance
services the city fails to provide
almost 40 years I've been here it's the
worst I've ever seen John Henry runs a
hotel near Union Square which has its
own community benefit district his
neighborhood has gotten so bad that he
routinely deals with horrified hotel
guests they are troubled by the
cleanliness the fact that they at times
don't feel safe seeing people who are
sleeping on the sidewalks and they're
baffled not all San Franciscans are
privileged enough to afford private
policing Co V Murphy sees no guard
bridge we try to keep it pretty clean
but since the city's prosecutors are
unwilling to enforce the law there's not
much patrol specials like Clemmons can
do where do they go they go to the next
corner and then you have
nice to see you too thank you for
it does get frustrating because as you
heard you offer services they don't want
services a lot of them choose to be on
the street because it's a lifestyle they
like our American dystopias Series
continues this entire week with things
as bad as they are there you might think
that housing in San Francisco might get
a little cheaper but somehow it's gotten
more expensive cost have become so
extreme that ordinary people with jobs
are trying desperate measures moving far
away those who want to stay close to
town live in boats in some cases now
missed part four of our series is
tomorrow 8:00 p.m. Eastern on this show